la voiture s'arrête ch détachement
ceinture j'essaie de sortir j'y arrive
je n'arrive pas à sortir et ma première
pensée ça a été de me dire que je dois
être sur le côté ou à l'envers et je
peux pas sortir parce que je suis bloqué
par le sol donc au début j'ai voulu
attendre qu'on vienne combien de m'aider
et puis assez rapidement je me rends
compte que en fait il ya du feu partout
et que j'ai pas le temps d'attendre donc
j'essaie de ressortir à nouveau je suis
bloqué et la jupe aussi bon bah en fait
voilà c'est terminé s'est terminée et
elle titre de mon livre la mort en face
c'est parce que pour moi la mort elle
s'arrêtait à 5 secondes de mon visage
elle a été en face de moi je n'ai
presque plus la matérialiser
et à ce moment-là je me dis non pour mes
enfants je peux pas enfin s'est pas posé
mes enfants mes enfants peuvent pas
grandir sans un père et je remets un
grand coup d'épaulé de être casque dans
tout ce qui était au dessus de moi et en
fait j'arrive à casser une pièce qui me
bloquait dans la voiture et a trouvé la
première fois la sortie
[Musique]
e
depuis l'accident j'ai deux dates de
naissance j'ai le 17 avril 1986 et j'ai
29 novembre 2020 je me considère comme
un coma survivants c'est sur un miraculé
aussi cet accident leur fait 100 x 99
fois le pilote sort pas vivant de des
flammes début mes gants rouges devenir
noir et je sais que j'ai les mains en
feu mais à ce moment là c'est pas grave
il aurait fallu que je m'arrache le pied
pour sortir de la voiture je l'aurais
fait
j'ai une main droite qui va très bien et
puis j'ai une main gauche qui est à voir
un peu moins jolie donc forcément il ya
une grosse brûlure une brûlure en fait
c'est un peu étrange comme une blessure
c'est guérit jamais vraiment et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui fonction de
l'humidité dans l'air de la météo ça va
me faire plus ou moins mal mais j'ai
appris à vivre avec et puis c'est pas
bien grave et c'est vrai que j'ai en
permanence je sers ma main comme ça je
la bouche pour que la peau continue de
la peau continue de travailler même un
an après donc on apprend à vivre avec ça
et en même temps c'est un peu une marque
de soldats
qui qui me rappelle ce que j'ai vécu et
qui me rappellent que chaque jour je
devrais pas être là et donc c'est un
bonus et il faut en profiter l'accident
a eu lieu le dimanche 29 novembre à 17
heures le mardi en fin de journée
j'étais déjà en visioconférence avec ma
psychologue qui je travaille depuis neuf
ans donc on se connaît très bien et puis
on a tout de suite travaillé pour éviter
tout ce qui était un stress post
traumatique et j'ai eu deux flash back
au mois de décembre de flashbacks
effectivement du moment où je me suis
dis bah ça y est c'est fini et presque
accepter de mourir et on en a
retravaillé dessus
et depuis plus rien j'ai jamais faite
cauchemar je peux voir les estime à de
l'accident je peux en parler assez
ouvertement
[Musique]
oh
on a un peu joué les vases communicants
c'est à dire qu'au début je disais tout
va bien j'ai pas mal ça va aller etc etc
parce que je savais qu'elle avait les
enfants à la maison elle il fallait
qu'elle gère aussi ce qu'elle avait vécu
parce que je pense que c'était plus dur
à suivre à la télé que ça ne l'était
dans la voiture et est donc au début
j'étais vraiment là pour la réconforter
et puis un moment quand on a commencé à
faire les soins un peu plus important
sur mes mains il a fallu faire ce qu'on
appelle un débris d'âge c'est à dire
couper la peau cloquée et je me suis
retrouvé avec des doigts à la chèvre a à
ce moment là c'est moi qui ai un coup de
moins bien et j'ai appelé marion et
c'est elle qui était là pour moi pour la
suite de ma vie pour ma main gauche
on doit faire attention donc je vais
rentrer avec marion à la maison voir mes
enfants
décision difficile je ne pensais pas
terminer ma carrière en formule 1 comme
ça mais je pense que c'est c'est pour le
mieux
[Musique]
quand je cours je dirais que la seule
chose aujourd'hui à laquelle je fais
beaucoup plus attention c'est dès qu'il
ya un accident je demande tout de suite
des informations et je suis beaucoup
plus inquiet sachant ce qui peut se
passer que je ne l'était à l'époque mais
après moi en termes tant que pilote
allait faire des dépassements ou rouler
vite faire ce que j'aime rouler engagé
ça il ya aucun il ya aucun blocage où
aucune séquelle de cet accident on sait
que malheureusement le sport automobile
reste reste un sport dangereux
extraordinaire mais dangereux j'ai porté
le cercueil de jules bianchi ans il ya
quelques années qui était un pilote de
formule 1 à un ami donc c'est sûr voilà
on vit des choses qu'on devrait pas
vivre à 30 ans mais on sait que ça fait
partie de notre métier
et que tant que les côtés positifs et la
passion est plus importante que le reste
on continue